فد ما هو وضع المرافق الصحيه في قطاع غزه
يتركز القصف بشكل كبير من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه على المرافق الصحيه
مستشفى الشفاء تعرض منذ صباح هذا اليوم
لاربع هجمات متكرره ومتواصله عليه كان اخر
هذه الهجمات استهداف لمبنى العيادات
الخارجيه داخل مجمع الشفاء مجمع الشفاء هو
اكبر المجمعات الطبيه اكبر المستشفى فيات
في قطاع غزه بالاضافه الى الجرحى الذين
يصلون والمرضى الذين هم داخل هذا المستشفى
هنالك عدد كبير من النازحين داخل هذا
المستشفى وليس بالطبع المستشفى الوحيد
الذي تعرض للقصف هذا اليوم مستشفيات اخرى
ايضا تعرضت للقصف منذ الامس بشكل مكثف
ومحيط هذه المستشفيات يتعرض بشكل كبير
لقصف من قبل قوات الاحتلال كما ان بعض
المستشفى فيات قد حوصرت المرافق الطبيه
التي تعاني اساسا هي اليوم يضاف الى
معاناتها قصف مباشر عليها
ومحيطها المفوض الاممي لحقوق الانسان دع
الى وقف كل اشكال العقاب الجماعي وقال انه
ليس هنالك مكانا امنا في قطاع غزه وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي تحدث عن جهود تبذل من
اجل ادخال المساعدات وخصيصا الوقود الى
قطاع غزه ولكن الى حد الان لا شيء من هذه
الوعود يلمس على الارض